a good leader has to spot the talented
resources the best people to do the
different jobs and the right products
the right direction to go so he was the
direction setter he just knew that I was
the best at what I did how did the
competition look at Apple today take you
seriously what happened when you first
got started we had no savings counts we
had no relatives or friends that could
loan us money we just had this drive we
wanted to build this computer one to
find a way to sell it how close were you
guys both of you of quitting at one
point where it got tough but he said
this may just not work out we should
just give it up and quit us along you
got to believe that you've got the
talent inside you got to believe it not
just pretending I typed something else
in the memory a yellow dot pops up I
called Steve Jobs on for him you know
that was a Eureka moment we were shaking
this is so big to become successful in
any field do you have to know everything
and everything about it you've got to
have somebody at least in the company
that has incredible drawing it's just
you know absolutely determined that you
know you're onto something big and we've
got to keep moving to get there and just
about everybody in Apple was that way
[Music]
and when you look at different
businesses whether it's sports whether
it's business whether it's a church
where there's some movement whatever it
is technology there are certain things
that do not change and those are
principles and these guys built a
business with principles of work ethic
and different things that we'll talk
about here today let me give me a story
about him when he when he got started
back in the days with Apple he was the
brains of that company he was the guy
that came who knew how to produce the
products who knew how to put the things
together he got started with the ideas
created a computers from there until
today he is alley legend I mean he is
like the Michael Jordan in the industry
of Technology all companies who go out
and produce things they prefer to have a
chance to ask for this man's advice this
is who that guy's in that world did
incredible things in a question I asked
last night is what would the world be
without Apple think about it I have an
iPhone here I have an iPad here we have
a bunch of Mac computers in the back
we got iPods all over the place what
would the world be without Apple think
about that if 1976-77 wouldn't happen
with the courage these people had so I
can go on talking all about him and what
he's done in the industry but please
help me bring up the one and only Steve
Wozniak
[Applause]
[Music]
so thank you for joining us Wow it's
incredible
it's been fun did you have fun last
night with us by the way I had a lot of
fun I didn't realize that the alarm
clock in my room had got set four hours
advanced so I woke up real early that's
not so I heard you know a lot of times
when when when we you know we bring
somebody in but hey let me say though
listening to you speak and the speaker
we had and the whole event in the awards
I have been to a lot of galas and a word
events for companies I have never been
to one as good as that and watching you
I mean I'm just totally sold because you
know what you have to do you're talking
about it's that that drive and wanting
to do something to make a difference and
you really bring that out and everyone
yourself absolutely so we start off all
the way to the bag on how the whole
thing got started I mean why don't you
just tell us how the story on how it got
started from the idea to avoid that sure
yeah I grew up so advanced in
electronics and computers that I
couldn't afford anything had no money
but I could design any computer there
was in the world in just a couple of
days and I just did it for fun it was a
hobby and I wanted my own computer I
told my dad at one point someday I'm
gonna have this particular computer of
my own and he said how you gonna do that
it cost as much as a house and I was
sort of stunned because I was young and
I said well I'll live in an apartment so
I would rather have a computer of my own
that I can just write programs on even
if it's just to play a game just to
solve a chess problem and eventually
what happened was I had a lot of luck
doing some extremely exotic design
things I got into the early stages of
arcade games designing games like
breakout for Atari and I just did that
on the side that was working for Hewlett
Packard designing the hottest gadget
product in the world
the HP scientific calculators changed
the world within about five years there
were no more slide rules sold every
engineer every scientist had to have one
of these HP calculators and I got to
design them I had no college degree but
they interviewed me and I knew so much
about it all that they hired me anyway
and while I was doing that I was
designing all sorts of little projects
the video games and terminals that I
could talk to computer
across the country and finally it I
realized the formula the day had come
when you could buy low enough cost
memory chips low enough microprocessors
that did enough I figured out in my head
the formula to building an affordable
computer and I said wow this is what
I've wanted for you know ten years I've
got it
I'm here and so how did that lead to UNC
I guess yeah he was a very good friend
five years before Apple even we met
because I had designed one computer and
some executive gave me some chips to
build it and I was building in a
friend's house and the friend introduced
me to Steve he said both you guys know
digital electronics so Steve came over
and described projects he did at Hewlett
Packard building frequency counters it
had displays of digits counting you know
frequencies of things like guitar chords
or whatever and I told him what I had
done how maíam all my experience and I
was sort of like the top young designer
you could ever run into in the times and
Steve was the man he was a leader he was
always trying to be one of those special
few people in the world the few that
take the steps forward you know like you
know a Newton he'd spoke of Newton and
and Shakespeare and things like that I
know that he really wanted to be one of
those people but he wanted to find
formulas to find the company and sell
things so every time I design something
really cute Steve would come by and say
I know how we can sell it so we're
always a partnership selling my little
project so but the whole thing got
started I read the story about how you
guys had this project underground
telephone long distance minute what was
that all about
telephone long distance um we're not
yeah my third year college at Berkeley I
I read an article that I thought was
just the most amazing fiction story ever
about these clever engineers that were
smarter than the engineers and the phone
company and they could turn the they
could set up their own little networks
and and find the bugs in the system and
help Ma Bell correct them and and it was
kind of honorable the way I read it and
Steve and III I called Steve up halfway
through the article and started reading
it to him and I said there's something
wrong this article sounds too real like
real people like real frequencies
they're telling us about we went down to
a scientific library that day I was
gonna start classes at college the next
day we went down to Stanford
accelerator center and in those days it
was the high-end physics research place
of the world smart people always leave
doors unlocked that's one thing I found
so we would drive in and we'd always
find a door unlocked to get into the
main building but they had a library
they had computer books they had
technical things and we verified that
this article was true you could put
tones into an American telephone and Dow
calls for free anywhere in the world you
gotta be kidding no the system had that
big of a flaw so I was amazed this is
like it's so amazing to know this nobody
knows it and I can show it off now I can
actually build a device and demonstrate
that show it off so to me it was more as
a comedian and and you know and bringing
people's attention to this weird
phenomena so um so I designed this
little box that would do it and Steve
said oh let's sell it okay and we sold
it we both sold it in the dorms to
people and for a year for a year for a
year I thought I was kind of you know
boy am my own phone calls I would pay
for them I wouldn't use it to save money
but I'd like to exploring the network
and being able to convince a Tokyo
operator that I was in New York operator
get her to put it over to London and
around the world and I'd call one phone
and speak in one phone and come up the
other one a second later it was very
weird back this is what I heard this is
a story I heard I don't know I heard you
were prankster yeah a lot of times you
hear stories anything people are so
serious to build something to speak you
got to be serious all the time
and I heard what that machine you
actually called the Pope yeah I called I
called the Italy Anwar to ask for Roman
word I got to the Vatican and they said
it was 5:30 in the morning I said I was
Henry Kissinger and and then so they
said well it's 5:30 in the morning call
back in you know later and I called back
at 6:30 in the morning their time and I
used a little bit of an accent to sound
little like Henry Kissinger at the
summit with Nixon in Moscow and the
bishop that answered said I just spoke
to Henry Kissinger busted well I guess I
guess one of the things you see with all
the great one is they push the envelope
and when you look at it when you and
Steve work together almost in like a
perfect partnership because of different
strengths that you have what Steve was
sort of like the leader he's always
looking for ways to turn things into a
product or a company make some money if
you
a good enough product and make enough
money you can make a better product with
that money and go up the ladder and that
was his approach and I was a good leader
has to spot the talented resources the
best people to do the different jobs and
the right products the right direction
to go so he was the direction setter and
he just knew that I was the best at what
I did so I was that part of the formula
and I designed all the early Apple
computers from scratch you know normally
you'd go to college and you learn
hardware you learned software you're one
of the other I did it all I did the
whole hardware I wrote the computer
programming languages I did every single
bit of the whole computer that's
unbelievers but but I did it not for a
company I did it because I wanted it
myself if you can convince somebody to
want something inside for their own
personal reason they really see
something that they want to do and they
really feel it in their heart that's
when you get a lot more done than any
you can't motivate people with a high
enough salary to do what you'll do when
it's for your own self there just show
off eating and not amazing so I guess
the question becomes this to become
successful in any field do you have to
know everything and everything about it
or is it is it kind of like you got to
put a good team together Wow you do need
some backgrounds of let's call it
education training you do need those
elements but a person knows how to take
the little elements and build on them
and formulate hit write the book of how
you actually put them into play a person
who comes up with BA the ability to
write the book I think is better than
someone who knows how to do it
from past experience because everything
I did at Apple it was an A+ job and that
took us places I had two things in my
favor
a I had no money that meant I had to
figure out ways to do things very
inexpensively I had to get a lot blood
out for the least in and B and I was
very good at that and B I've never done
them before every single Apple project
computers hard disks everything I had
never designed those things ever in my
life I had had no training in them but I
was so good at taking the little parts
like pieces of wood to build a building
that I could architect something that
was perfect and really better than
people that were used to doing it would
do that some believe yeah so if I had
had experience
I would have designed things with 50
chips instead of eight chips
traditionally yeah that's interesting
you say that what did Ronald Reagan
recognize you for I think it was in 1986
or 87 the first national medal of
technology was created in 1986 I think
and yeah the President Ronald Reagan
gave the awards to me and Steve Jobs
we're in the first set of recipients
because Apple was you know really doing
a lot of good for the world and the
economy that always helps a president
but you're wrong Reagan was one of the
early presents that they all speak out
we got to have more emphasis on
technology on innovation and to me I
thought wow they're gonna have more math
classes in science classes in schools
it's never happened so it's there's
there's a lot of talk everywhere but
it's very hard it'll get translated into
a couple little projects that are
nowhere near what you ever hear of
intelligence in our schools is defined
as always having the same answers
everyone else you go home you watch this
a new show you come back and talk about
current events you all say the same
thing and not one person says no that
doesn't make sense to me that one person
is really taught to think for themselves
or that's called not intelligence we're
taught how to calculate when two canoes
will meet on a river the rivers flow in
five miles an hour you know and we never
we should teach kids to raise their hand
and say no that wouldn't work because
you can't predict the water will be
exactly five miles an hour they're gonna
be wind and you know why don't we we you
know think to think about these things
be skeptical a bit we don't really teach
that way we just teach come up with the
same answer that everyone else would
well then you're just one in a billion
but it's an equation being a follower
instead of a leader the only it's not
kind of controversial though isn't that
kind of controversial to do the opposite
what everybody else has done well I
think well some schools like Montessori
schools get around you know do some
better job at that but you know we just
our whole system of schools is is
unfortunately very bad because it's
based on money and money and especially
in a democracy you got a problem schools
are funded by the government they're all
funded by the government and government
has slices of pie that go into different
sectors usually according to how much
money there is there or how
votes well the funny thing is for
schools kids don't get a vote
what that translates to is a family of
five gets no more say than a family of
two and the family too doesn't want to
spend money on schools and the family of
five does so you've got this controversy
where you're constantly outvoted by the
the masses you didn't really the kids
don't get counted as a as a vote in the
you know determining how much money
schools are worth and need so schools
are always gonna be short of money short
of money it means you have to have a
large class and everybody doing the same
thing and there's no you can't have any
randomness well you know and I think
randomness and even a little misbehavior
is really essential to creative people
well Steve I was a kid that had a 4.0
GPA I followed the system the rules to
the tea everything I did perfectly
obviously I'm being sarcastic with it
I had a 1.2 GP I filled most my classes
except math I love math that was it I
mean I could listen to that stuff all
day long but let's change gears I've got
a question for you about this so Steve
Jobs was Steve Jobs an expert I mean an
expert in designing the Apple one the
Apple 2 the saw I mean the computers was
he an expert in that area
Steve understood it and he knew how to
listen to which people were telling the
best stories he couldn't quite design
things he wasn't quite an engineer level
but he was close to it because of his
understanding of electronics so he
wasn't an engineer he couldn't I don't
think he ever wrote a program software
so no he but he understood the value of
them but at first it was just mainly
what could sell he could compare to
other devices and he knew what would
sell he had worked selling in surplus
stores where all these little extra
electronic parts came and he would know
how to buy some switches for six cents
that he could sell to somebody for six
bucks
so was he what was he more salesman or a
technology guy he was well he was a good
mix you know what when you have a guy at
the talk he's got to be good at sale
sales is where your income comes from
but he should also be able to if you've
got a guy at the top of a company that
understands the technology and can talk
to the engineers and not be totally lost
and just say you do what you're doing
I trust you yeah that's good and he was
he was sort of he had a
good understanding of it which helped I
mean although although really the story
of Apple is a little misunderstood
because it's like Steve and I did it
ourselves and we really with the Apple 2
computer we got funding a guy funded us
an angel and he joined us and he had
made his money working in marketing and
Intel and as an engineer before and he
was a mentor he was kind of young but he
was wealthy and he owned as much of
Apple as Steve and I did same amount of
stock Mike Mark was his name and he ran
our marketing but he was our mentor he
told us how we would organize the
company what Steve's roles would be what
my role would be so he was really more
responsible for apples success than
anyone but he kind of lays out of the
picture because Steve and I came from
nothing we had no savings accounts we
had no relatives or friends that could
loan us money we had we just had this
drive we wanted to build this computer
one to find a way to sell it and you
know and and for a while we were getting
the parts on 30 days credit with no
money and we'd build the computers in 10
days and sell them for cash at the store
so that was that was how we ran for you
know a good year with the Apple one
computer but interest because we had
nothing ourselves the interest think I
read an accident a million about shoe is
you had a full-time job when you start
at Apple so you were part-time with
Apple and he had a full-time job while
building an Apple company that's right I
worked for Hewlett Packard I loved Keela
Packard I had determined in my life I
didn't want to be a high up run other
people's lives person I didn't want to
get into be political I didn't want to
be a manager I was gonna be an engineer
for life and the greatest engineering
company in the in the country was
Hewlett Packard everyone was building
products that other engineers used I
mean that was my life forever I would
never leave HeLa Packard
so I made sure when we came up with the
Apple computers and Steve suggested
starting the company oh I tried to talk
Hewlett Packard and to do it five times
they turned me down five times they four
five times the first time I spoke of the
idea of a little machine for $800 you
could type your programs in and see them
on your home TV and they turn it down
for some good reasons Hewlett Packard
couldn't have built the product the
right way when your your company culture
establishes your product has to be very
boring and
engineer strictness about it you know
you can't use normal things that normal
people have like a normal cassette tape
recorder distort programs so they really
would have done the project all wrong
and eventually they did then when we got
the order for completely and said we
were gonna sell little PC boards for
forty bucks each at first then when we
got the order to sell them with all the
parts in whoa we're selling everyone for
$500 I got scared so I went to Hewlett
Packard's legal department and I have
them research what we were gonna do set
or send it around to every Hewlett
Packard division and they all turned it
down they all turned it down and then
when we started a project in our lab
aquila Packard right on my floor of the
building I went over and I said I I
really calculators aren't my life
computers are I want to be on this
computer project you're doing they
started a computer project a little
microprocessor just like I had used a
bunch of dynamic memory like I had come
to use they had five guys writing a
basic language and I have just written
one myself so I've done it all and I
said I'll do any meaning you know menial
job I'll do a printer interface a little
dinky job but I want to be on this
project and they turned me down I read a
story that Atari almost bought you or
Commodore $400,000 and offered a $20,000
salary for you and Steve that's accurate
that's totally inaccurate okay the real
truth is Steve and I went into Commodore
first we walked up we had the Apple to
design but we had no money now you've
got a computer that you know his heart
and you can sell a thousand though and
we didn't give it away I gave away the
Apple one public domain
no copyright no nothing the Apple 2 was
too valuable for that and we took in the
Commodore and we're sitting there they
said well what do you want and Steve
says well we'd like you know a few
hundred thousand dollars and I shared up
my salary was twenty five thousand at
the time and he says and we'd like to
you know have stock and we'd like to
have a position running the whole thing
and and I was just how could you ask for
so much that's just like we're asking
for the world and Commodore turned us
down they had a guy that joined them
that had come to our garage I
demonstrated the Apple two and he went
to cobbler and said people don't want
color they don't need graphics they
don't need all these fancy things they
just want cheap
isn't that amazing and the funny thing
is their machine was actually more
expensive than ours because it didn't
use your home TV your home TV is free
for output so Commodore I went their own
way and lucky for us Atari loved us and
they left the product but they were
about to come out with the first home
pong game ever they were gonna make
millions of dollars off this and they
had their hands full you don't you don't
want to divert from the one big project
to try to do something new but
eventually of course but Atari also got
into these home computers so you know
that's how it seemed and I wait we went
on a long course to try to get the money
we went to venture capitalists and they
said you guys are too you know we're not
young 20s we didn't speak business talk
we'd never had business experience never
taken a business course and then we
wound up with the angel Mike Merkel and
I was a big thing that once that took
place he saw he saw he saw and believed
that this product was going to be one of
those categories that was going to be
successful and pop up in so many homes
and be one of those huge startups that
grows to a billion dollars in five years
back in those days money how many
doubters did you guys have people that
doubted that this will never happen how
many what doubters many doubters at
first before Steve joined that he was up
in Oregon I was going to a club a
computer club and people were starting
to talk about the revolution that was
going to come they haven't found the
formula to build the right computer yet
that could sell to the non-techies but
boy we were just so gung-ho about how we
were gonna revolutionize education and
communication and and calculating the
finances for companies and everything
and and I forgot what the question was
I think I asked them what I asked of you
guys doubters companies the big computer
companies like Digital Equipment the
many computer companies all kept saying
oh it's gonna go away it's gonna be a
little hobbyist thing it's not gonna be
important money-wise it's not so we had
there were a lot of official high-level
doubters but eventually and the analysts
were not not really predicament was
gonna be a big market until just about
when we started with the aptitude the
analysts were about to finally conceive
this home computer market was gonna be
big so the first day Apple get started
firstly Apple get started how was that
all about how did that whole dream get
started the first day well the first day
I mean I was I had this computer that I
was giving away all the designs for
freely free yes Steve Jobs just said
came back from Oregon and saw it and he
said wow let's uh you know we should
sell these PC boards build them for $20
sell it for $40 and didn't know if we'd
we'd have to come up with a few hundred
bucks each and that was tough
I had to sell the most valuable thing I
owned my hewlett packard 65 calculator
sold it for 500 bucks and only got 250
the guy never showed up again but so so
we put a few hundred bucks in to make
this pc board and then we got a little
bit bigger interest there's the owner of
the local story but looking over my
shoulder at the computer club i would
just type on a keyboard little board
with a bunch of little you know
accountable number of $1.00 chips and
this thing is actually running software
and programs and and so he decided he
wanted to buy the complete things all
built and we didn't quite supply the ap1
completely built we didn't have time to
get cases and power supplies done that
was the Apple 2 that was later um and
when when the Apple 2 came along yes
Steve and I both looked each other it
was the day that I had come up with this
little idea in my head when I was in a
dreamy state you know when you lose
sleep how you get a little creative
thinking I was down at Atari and we had
a job Steve came to me he said you have
to design this project in four days and
back then a game and after arcade game
was not a program it was not software
and it would take six months so I had to
do it in four days Wow I was great
I said I don't know if I can do this we
stayed up without sleep for four days
and nights both got mononucleosis the
sleeping sickness and delivered it but
while my head was sort of half awake and
half asleep I saw this thing on the
factory floor of Atari all the games
were black-and-white TVs there's one
game it was going back and forth
changing color and my eyes couldn't
quite focus I was so tired it's weird it
was like hypnotic it was like you're at
a light show at a concert and they had
little mylar coverings on the TV red
green blue yellow and made it look color
so I went back to a lab bed Steve was
was wiring up my design on one side of
the lab and I'm on the other side
thinking color television I remember how
the frequencies go from high school
electronics what if I and then I came up
with this little method of taking a
little one chip digital putting ones and
zeros in it
cycling around one zero one zero one
zero up down up down up down I could
make it look like color TV would it work
it doesn't it's not the formulas they
have always complicated calculus and
hundreds of parts and thousand dollars
to generate color you know on you know
in TV stations would this little idea
with a $1 chip work and the day that I
actually built it the app for the first
Apple to prototype and I could type
something to memory and a blue dot pops
up on the screen of the TV I typed
something else into memory a yellow dot
pops up I called Steve Jobs over and you
know that was a Eureka moment we were
shaking this is so big this is you know
all the colored games are now going to
be on computers everything that all
started with you the color yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah that was a really incredible
life right my best
[Music]
bring bringing color to the world you're
not in Kansas anymore that's why we
chose a six color logo for our first
logo from Apple we were the ones that
brought color because nobody would have
ever expected
color on an affordable computer much
less the graphics that we had and we
even had pixels so you could almost have
photographs on a screen no it was so far
ahead of its time
that everybody else was gonna have to
sit back and figure out ways to do it
IBM did on the PCs did a horrible
horrible attempt at color they just said
your letters can be a certain color and
their background could be a color but we
really didn't they didn't really do
graphics pure like we did how close were
you guys both of you of quitting at one
point where it got tough what he said
this may just not work out we should
just give it up and quit and sell off we
never went through that phase at Apple
no we were just we were in a new
revolutionary product area all the press
of the world was yes home computers are
gonna come because they kind of didn't
believe it and didn't know what it was
but there was nobody really saying in
the press oh this is a horrible idea
because largely it didn't look like it
was gonna be big money so there was no
reason for the big companies to poopoo
it in the press so really it was getting
just gung-ho I mean it was thing we
thought we were on top of a revolution
and we knew that at Apple we were the
leaders so everybody we hired in those
early years young people old people we
hired competent people in every
department if we hadn't done that we
wouldn't be here but we just everybody
felt that we were just leading the whole
new world and things were gonna go up
and up and up forever and nobody left
the company for years a few years till
we went public so it was it was really
we didn't have oh my gosh let's pack it
up and quit
there were times there was a time when
it came time to actually take the money
and I don't want to be part of the I
don't wanna be big money I really don't
and I didn't want to run companies and
tell other people what to do and I was
so kind of a nice too much of a nice guy
that I would probably get kicked out
real quickly so I you know I wanted to
design computers so there was a
condition I had to leave Hewlett Packard
and I loved that company
and I'm so loyal that didn't warn me I
said why do I feel a Packard in one year
I've designed two computers I've written
a basic I've done all these these
cassette tape interfaces and other
interfaces for printers and things I've
done all that on the side why don't I
just keep working on the side and the
investor said I had to leave he loved
Packard I went on the ultimatum day I
went to his cabin and I said no I'm not
gonna start after I want to design
computers but I'll do that on my own
time and Steve Jobs went into a frenzy
and he got all my friends and relatives
to start calling me and finally one very
very trusted friend convinced me that I
could start Apple and I could stay an
engineer and just do it to make money
and I said that's why you're not amazing
so nothing wrong with making money off
what you do no it was the motive
initially of money or was it to
revolutionize an industry for you guys
it was more to revolutionize an industry
but money is partly the way to do it you
have to have successful success in the
products to be able to build another
higher level product to take you further
and further out and I know Steve was
very Steve Jobs was very scared right
away big company names like you were
talking last night IBM oh my gosh
they're gonna they're gonna kill us and
our marketing guy Mike Barclay said he
said no no no even at a big company it
boils down to a small group and we're a
small group and we've got a lead and if
we think as well as they if we have a
smarter people as they have will do the
job and will that will keep your market
share so it sounds like you played a big
role in a company oh absolutely
huge role well he basically from day one
said Apple should be a marketing driven
company you should understand your
customers needs and the price of the
products and competitive products and
that's how you decide what you're going
to do and then engineering more follows
directions where I was coming from
hewlett-packard where it was an
engineering driven company engineers in
every phase of the management from the
founders on down and we're building
products for engineers so we were the
market we could understand what made
sense in our products and ideas for the
next product that would you know turn
the company hewlett-packard around for
10 years might come from a low-level
engineer Wow so how much how much does
courage play a role in starting the
company and getting part of something
going against a bigger guy
how big of a role does courage play Wow
I think it's like going on Dancing with
the Stars you you don't know if you can
do it and you're afraid to fail but I'll
tell you that drives you to work harder
and try harder than you've ever done in
your life
you do have to you have to be confident
you have to seem confident that's
important you have to appear confident
as far as we didn't take really great
risks I mean I sold my calculator it was
my most valuable thing but I sold it for
five hundred dollars in theory and I
knew that the next month we were coming
out with the HP 67 a better one and my
employee price would be 370 so I didn't
take a financial risk yeah finally
leaving you a Packard going out on my
own it was a big risk but it was a risk
with a real strong belief that the
product was good so when we see the
company from outside and we see Apple
and we're using our iPhone or iPad you
know all this stuff that we use it when
you first got started with the Apple
what was the work ethic like I mean how
did you guys work with the hours and the
sacrifices how did that take part in
this taking place at first we had really
no such things hours I mean pretty much
everybody was in full day times of
course when you're a programmer or an
engineer sometimes you don't have
something fixed at 5 p.m. 6 p.m. 8 p.m.
midnight 2 a.m. you'd go home very tired
maybe you get it fixed maybe you don't
that's just the life of an engineer my
whole life ever even when I was just a
young student who loved it loved
electronics and nothing else I'd stay up
as late as I could when something was
close to being done that's what drives
you especially software so we just had
kind of one room much smaller than this
and about five desks at first and then
seven everybody to see everybody and we
got another little tiny office because
we hired a guy that the other people
didn't like too much so to get him out
of their way I loved him he was the guy
that known as Captain Crunch with the
blue boxes that called all over the
world had him develop a great foam board
that could make a phone call in the
early days of modems can make a phone
call on your phone lightly before modems
really
more modems that we know today that can
dial it would dial a call and listen is
it busy is it answering it could listen
to the tones and tell like a human could
and that wasn't going to happen in
modems for another 12 years this thing
was way ahead of its time because so it
could dial it could send out tones and
it could listen to the tones and he set
it up he wrote programs without 5000
calls a day trying to crack some codes
successfully so so work you think
there's no hours when you start a gig
there's no such thing as you're working
9:00 to 5:00 this and this and you're
working your tail off to start the
company off no any yeah any any you know
entrepreneurship because I've been
around so many I love young people
they're like we were that like Steve and
I starting their own little business and
they've got their ideas and hanging
around them and to go I mean y'all we
see it though they're usually young
people look at the people who started
Apple look at the people started Google
and Facebook very young people just out
of college you know and there's infinite
time in the world if you're really
motivated to do something you don't have
all the obligations of family and
expenses and things that take a lot of
your you know make it harder to come up
with that time here's a difference that
does make a huge difference i you could
never add up the amount of hours we
would put into these projects here's a
question about entrepreneurship you see
well one thing I see is you know there
are very common commonality similarities
between people who win in different
fields what basic principles would you
say that it's common in order to want to
become successful as an entrepreneur
what could you say to the guys who that
are here for the first time maybe saying
if you want to make it as an
entrepreneur this is what you need to do
these days entrepreneurship is taught as
courses in all the colleges and usually
it's a business level course so you've
got all these business guys that oh my
gosh if I write some ideas down on paper
that's how you go about it starting a
company and all right my principle is no
I so many people in Silicon Valley got
used to write ideas down on paper and
then try to get some money probably some
money try to get some money like we can
just buy the engineering for it no I
like the type of entrepreneurship that
has actually created working models here
is an example of something that works
the way we want it and we built it and
we've got the the talented the talented
technical
people that know how to do it and I
think it should get to that phase so the
Entrepreneurship it's a combination of
the business and the technical doers the
technology people so competence work
ethic business combined together
yep and you but you've got to have
somebody at least in the company that
has incredible Drive that just you know
absolutely determined that you know
you're onto something big and we got to
keep moving to get there and just about
everybody in Apple what's that way just
about everybody in Apple was yeah we
believe we were really really getting
making going a long ways making a lot of
money in a very short time is a big big
attraction Wow so what what what what
what did you see yesterday when you saw
the you know you're seeing the whole can
take in place people coming up on stage
going crazy guys weren't in spandex
football jerseys all this other stuff
you know what did you think yesterday
similarities to how Apple was with the
fire with us in this industry your head
HP's ahead I have to say
when we should let me started Apple we
were a lot more subtle with we didn't
have award ceremonies for quite a while
and recognizing the people's
accomplishments there weren't very many
of us you know there weren't very many
engineers for a while I was the one
engineer so there wasn't a place to
recognize accomplishments I guess your
name could pop up on a patent what's the
best the most it would be no I like that
I was I was smiling heavily all through
that thing last night because they had I
was in the backs of people who take
pictures and I wouldn't be blocking the
way so no but I I was really yeah it's
really good to see I really hope that
everybody out there is a real come
through star and you know I think you
got to believe in yourself you got to
believe that you've got the talent
inside and then you've got to actually
present that you got to believe it not
just pretend it so you you mentioned one
thing you said we recruited people to
come on board that all were good at what
they did so recruiting was very critical
for the success of Apple we did some
recruiting we lucked out by having a few
good people around us to begin with our
Thunder was incredible at marketing
whereas all these other little hobbyist
companies didn't have anybody you know
his caliber at all and you know my
excellence and engineering was well
known and but then what we hired people
we looked around we needed a guy that
has odd runs the operations he's the guy
that when things aren't getting done and
need a little attention he gets on their
backs and makes the phone calls make
sure they get busy so that parts of the
company don't hold up Mike Scott was our
president from the day we started till
the day we went public
you never hear his name but he was it
was an incredible experience
we hired very good salespeople and
accountants right from the start we had
quality people in the company not just a
whole bunch of kids
that's good that's exciting when you
hear that because you know at the end of
the day you're putting a team together
and when I read this story about Apple
it seems like people played their roles
everybody took responsibility playing
their roles
yeah all the various disciplines were
well had good people behind them and
then I looked back after just a couple
of years why is Apple going so well and
all these other companies every single
other one is started in our little
homebrew Computer Club faded away why
what was the difference and we're really
we had the good people in all the
different categories you need that was
probably the main thing for a start-up
absolutely that's great to know
you know I watched one of your
interviews in 1984 and you were at your
home you had your three dogs with you
and in this interview you said this you
said perhaps once a decade a very large
market new market comes from zero up to
billions of dollars within a few years a
new group of people come out right you
said this in an interview so when these
groups come out what are some of the
commonalities these groups have in
common that go from zero to billion
dollars I'm not talking about the groups
of people as much as I am about the
industry a new industry gets formed and
it might be you know color television
and something comes along you know
personal computers came along really
with Apple and when that that whole
market the whole market expands so great
that's when companies can become join
the big leagues in a very short number
of years did you guys initially think
you were gonna become the big leagues
and become this 200 330 billion dollar
company I mean powerhouse worldwide was
that something that you you knew this
was gonna happen or what's a vision you
casted saying let's see if that's gonna
take place well if you asked us a
question back then are you gonna be
thirty billion dollars in 2010 what you
know I think I would just invoke
exponential laws or you know and say of
course we will because money will
deflate to or you know there's there's a
lot of different ways to come up with
that but we we truly believe within five
years we would be huge that there would
be computers in every house that we were
going to be one of those companies that
doesn't go away doesn't get consumed by
others we were very individualistic and
proud of what we've done and boy now I
realize how lucky how rare that is yeah
a lot of it an awful lot of good
companies start out and they seem to
have all the right pieces and formulas
and still drop off and it's it's hard to
say why you know it's even hard to say
why why MySpace and Facebook
it sure is you know you you look at this
stories of computer
in the book accident a millionaire talks
about how computers back in early 1900s
the one that was designed the number
they said is 40 tons roughly and when
they turned it on in Philadelphia the
lights in the entire city went down when
it would turn on this computer to go
from a computer that's 40 tons to come
and make a PC that's doing the pot you
gotta be a little bit crazy to think
you're gonna do something like that um a
little bit that's true but the world was
going down to where the computers were
getting smaller and smaller using less
and less power doing much more work due
to advances in technology the vacuum
tubes of the old days took a lot of
power I've got to watch with vacuum
tubes in it and they run on the camera
zooming on this by the way can we out
there you guys got to see this for this
let's have the camera zoom in on this
watch yeah when I turn this plane it
displaced hours and minutes the little
three volt battery has boosted up to 140
volts to run those vacuum tubes called
Nixie tubes which are the display and so
in the old days things were high-powered
that televisions got hot you know you
took the tubes down to the grocery store
that when they burned out I mean that
was part of our life then transistors
came along Silicon Valley was one of the
big hearts of transistors and we had
little transistor radios that ran on a
small battery and they could run for a
week on it and then we had chips and now
with chips you could build larger and
larger projects at first the military
could you know make spaceships weigh
less but eventually you could build
computers out of chips and then the
chips got better and better and
eventually an entire computer was on one
chip and all you had to do was design IO
stuff around it and so everything got
shrunk and shrunk and shrunk and today
we have the iPhone and it's obviously a
million times the computer and a
millions the power
[Applause]
but some of those steps along that way
could have delayed things if they
haven't happened
so starting Apple I think was one of the
good steps that really took the world
over quicker by spotting the spotty
little formulas of how to make things at
a certain cost I think that's always the
heart of it it's you know if you have
the better price you win well it seemed
that what I got from what you just said
right now is the fact that you know
doing the impossible yes somebody's
gonna do it because somebody's gonna
come out and make something bigger and
better anyway that's what it's meant to
be you know what is the future hold in
technology what do you think about the
future I mean we have iPods iPhones
iPads what is the future or with
technology the way we communicate with
computers is called input and outputs
okay and it used to be just a big old
typewriter and it would type back to you
teletype machine and then it went to the
apples of the Apple style with just a
keyboard and a video screen that could
display things and then we got graphics
a better output style a picture can
sometimes tell the mind something much
more quickly you know pictures worth a
thousand words and and and it allowed us
to then drag things we got the mouse but
the mouse is remote-controlled when I
want to move something on a table I used
my hand the mouse was a remote control
still it was a little more human but a
little not perfectly there we tried to
make the computer world seem more and
more like human paradigms I have a
screen on a computer we started calling
it a desktop because everyone has a
desktop it's familiar we were trying to
make these computers friendly to the
person that's afraid of computers afraid
of the word and these days now we've got
the touchscreens I just love it I love
even my ipod nano watch just swipe it
along instead of pressing buttons it's
just much more comfortable the way the
way you use these things and I don't
know why it's a body actually when it
feels good about something I prefer it
sure somebody can type things on their
blackberry whatever and do it just as
fast but I don't know there's a thing in
you like you enjoy the way it works now
what I enjoy the most these days though
is on all my smart phones both iPhones
and androids
I enjoy it where I can speak commands
into them
because I don't have to think I don't
have to think how do I do this where is
this little program what do I click to
put it into a certain mode and then what
do I click to put in some data I don't
have to do that I just speak to it I'll
speak to you know call Janet mobile or
I'll speak you know navigate to Ruth's
Chris Steakhouse in Las Vegas make a
reservation for Ruth's Chris take on the
Apple I love using the Siri assistant
make a reservation for six people at
Ruth's Chris Steakhouse in Las Vegas at
8 p.m. Tuesday night and it does it all
and I just have to press one little
confirm button it's all done on the web
so this world's getting more and more to
the speech recognition being better and
better you know what's the largest lake
in California and I get the answer I
didn't have to go into Google and type
things with my finger or my my keyboard
I really love doing that what's your
night sorry I think eventually we're
gonna be speaking almost everything to a
phone and you know maybe every single
program that you app with app that you'd
like to use on your phone will include
its own little speech dictionaries so
you'll just have to say the name of an
app and then tell it what to do in its
own dictionary so that the same phrase
doesn't have to be met you don't have to
memorize a billion phrases you've got
infinite things that it can do I don't
want to get into that but we had a
language it out will it work that way
called Apple script what's your thoughts
on social media Twitter Facebook what do
you think about when he saved you know
Facebook's Twitter's YouTube I'm a poor
person to ask about about those sort of
things I mean I think they're very
they're obviously so important and you
get a lot of value out of them I get a
lot of value out of Facebook and Twitter
I just have time to use them because I'm
so hung up in so much email and then
I've got I now have probably 2,000
Facebook friends that I don't even know
but they asked me politely
they said something nice about me and I
said okay they're an Apple Apple fan
okay and I've got 2,000 fans and I don't
really know so now I get a new social
media and it says do you want to link it
to your Facebook friends oh my god so
all of a sudden I'm gonna have 2,000
people I don't know on this new one to
know so I have to I have to leave those
links out and those links are very
important for normal people to be able
to link all of your social worlds
to each other and include them like I
may go on to just something since
birthday cards do you want to get you to
want to link it to your Facebook no I
don't I don't you know this it's too
huge so I have to I have to avoid those
things a bit and at first it cost me to
think well they weren't really doing
anything new that we didn't have before
we had webpages we had email we had
interactions online we had a lot of chat
methods so you know what is it it's just
sort of a nice holding place if you
think back 15 20 years AOL hey well when
it started it was Macintosh only but AOL
was the first one that brought graphics
to this kind of a world but you were in
your own little private world with your
friends your people your buddies and
your little chat rooms and it was very
similar environment back then which is
probably why it was so successful in its
day let's switch gears and let's talk
about Ron Wayne yeah I read an article
mill a times when you guys got started
and initially because you know you were
younger in your 20s the industry may not
take you seriously so you about somebody
who was Ron way experience I think it
was an Atari and you made him a 10%
owner initially and you were 45 Steve
was 45 and 12 days later Ron comes back
and he sells off his 10% saying I want
to sell it back to you for $800 that 10%
today would be worth 22 billion dollars
if he was still there what happened with
wrong way what was that story Bob I
remember if 12 days is right but um
Steve came to me at one point he said
okay we're I finally a culet Packard had
turned me down and we're gonna start
this company to make these little $20 PC
boards for him sell him for forty and he
came to me and he said look there's this
guy he kind of respected Ron's thinking
Ron wasn't one of these arch
conservatives reading all the
conservative books of the time you know
today he'd be considered a wacko but but
it makes him sound very authoritative
and he had so much experience in
companies and having sparking some
companies and getting screwed by the
executives and knowing how these things
work and he attracted Steve Jobs so
Steve said well let's hire we can hire
him and he will he'll do
manual forest is good at doing manuals
he sat down to typewriter and typed out
a our partnership agreement all the
legal phrases and words and and I mean I
don't know how a person knows how to do
that he was incredibly talented he drew
the sketch an etching by hand of Newton
under the apple tree for our first the
cover of our first Apple one manual and
and he was great I know he was with us
more than 12 days though and so so
Steve's proposed that Ron would have 10%
sort of Stephen I disagreed about
something Ron could could resolve it and
I met Ron and was wow so impressed he
knew all these different things and he
referred me to a bunch of books and when
I got home they were kind of trashed to
me none dare call it treason and that
kind of stuff that but I really
respected his ability to think and and
to resolve things the right way so that
was his purpose and then what happened
was we got this order out of thin air to
build computer boards with with parts on
them and sell them for 500 each a
$50,000 order and like I said my salary
25,000 this was scary stuff because down
were in big business and I don't want to
make you laugh Packard's think I'm you
know doing something buying their bags
well what happened was we'd get the
parts on 30 days credit build into 10
days as I said deliver them to the store
and Ron Wayne figured out that what if
something goes bad and we don't get paid
then who owes the money on the parts
what turns out that Steve Jobs had zero
bank account you know I had zero bank
account no savings account no nothing
none of us had any wealthy friends so
Ron Wayne all his money would be at
stake so he was taking 100% of the
financial risk for 10% of the company
and it was too flaky and he and he sold
out he you know he didn't have a vision
there was a big picture but it was so
early with just the Apple one it was
hard to see where Apple would go the
Apple to really changed the story and
that came about three months later so it
takes a little bit of it I think Ron was
with us for a few months he was with you
for a few months yeah so what was his
reason for quitting outside of that did
he have outside influence that say these
guys may get sue these guys maybe
out of business these guys may have this
I never heard a reason for Ron quitting
Steve just told me he wanted to sell
sell out and he walked away I'm so I'm
guessing his reason his reason he would
have been good and he walked away from
it yeah and very happily and so is he an
Apple fan I guess that'd be a question
area every time he looks at Apple that's
12 billion dollars right there
I actually talked to him now and then
and he's a little on the poor side so
he's can't always afford Apple stuff
yeah that's what that's that's actually
what it said in the article yeah it said
in the article he now collects stamps
and sells coins to supplement a Social
Security income and you know you hear a
story like that you feel bad because you
know the opportunity was so but that's
so common in other industries as well
people hear a story they they come in
they want to be part of the last minute
they get afraid and they want to walk
away from well let's talk about this
last thing because I don't we only got a
few minutes here let's wrap it up when
did you know Steve that you were there
with with the big boys you were there
where your competitors started saying
okay you got to be careful with Apple
when did that happen were you guys kind
of said okay I think we're getting there
well what happened was the first killer
app a spreadsheet came out and then a
spreadsheet made this computer so
valuable to any small businessman
calculate all your income and expenses
month by month by month make a change
and see that the bottom line months
later that all of a sudden the shale
sales shot up ten times we went into you
know heavy overdrive to ramp up and
within about a year of that we had the
floppy disk come in the we now we've
been in business two years and we were
just selling so much that you we didn't
our stock wasn't on the market or
anything but its value was pretty huge
Steve came to me one day and he said you
realized that our stock is worth more
than our parents have made in their life
so very early then you know a year later
went public and that was a huge that's
you so pretty much you know it by the
one thing of course we were just
nobody ever said
Apple to computer which was designed by
oh yes yeah very familiar and our first
Apple to computer let me tell you an
important part about Steve Jobs when we
designed it I did all the computer stuff
all the hardware all the software and
Steve Steven knew a guy that made
motorcycle seats out of a foam process
in Palo Alto this guy could make some
cases for us so Steve actually worked on
with an artist to draw some case designs
up and came up with the general design
of the case kind of like a typewriter
very nice case very young very efficient
and thought out well thought out the way
it works so we our first cases didn't
have these little grooves here so they
were that's how you can tell the very
earliest ones but that guy could only
make us like 12 a day you know we're
begging him we're sending that engineer
over every day to his house to try to
get 20 of them and we finally we had to
send off in to make real plastics
overseas we finally got that it saved
the company so please put this in
perspective this computer's power can
pay it compared to today's computer
probably one millionth 1 million yeah
this one this one has for example it
originally came with 4 Kbytes of memory
now 4 gigabytes is considered small a
million times more the speed of this one
was 1 million and the speed of today's
is obvious several billions so that's
thousands of times more the speed call
it maybe ten thousand times one yeah so
but it did the job and it did it well
and fun and did just what I was supposed
to doing and everyone who had one loved
it when did this first come out 1977 we
put this out I design and it was so far
ahead of its time and there but the best
of all is I built in a lot of game stuff
and tell people computers should be fun
you should have a fun element in your
work I watched that video last night I
mean that's really you got to have the
people you know laughing and smiling
does they do their job in talking to
each other absolutely so so so we can
put this up here
so question about competitors when you
first got started how did the
competition look at Apple today did they
take you seriously your first year did
they I mean did they laugh at you did
they spread rumors there was there a lot
of propagandas I mean what happened when
you first got started how do they look
at you the the Apple one was you know I
developed that and gave it away at the
Computer Club and it was selling pretty
pretty well and we was it was really the
best little complete computer for the
price you could buy but one company in
our club looking over my shoulder they
had the formula so they built their next
computer with a keyboard and a little
video display it was called the
processor technology saw it became the
hot seller using the Intel chips which I
didn't use and cuz they were too
expensive for me so it became the hot
seller selling up to a thousand a month
for a brief period and then we had the
Apple to which we knew was ten times the
computer that was color that was
graphics it was games it was it was
really everything and and we knew we had
the hot one so we knew we'd sell a
thousand a month of it and we really
have no competition for quite a while
probably one to two years yeah we had we
had a couple of early competition
products but like I said they were just
cheap by comparison they didn't have
color that in their graphics they they
were limited their memory you couldn't
expand it I built this thing the way
computer people build computers you
could increase the memory if you don't
have enough you can add more if you if
you need to think of a device like a
floppy disk you can add a card connected
to a floppiest
so they weren't expandable and what
happened was when that program the
spreadsheet came out visit Delft this is
the only one of those computers the
three of them that existed that had
enough memory to run it so they had to
write it for this computer only so
basically everybody else had to go back
to the drawing board and make computers
that could add floppy disks and things
and could add more memory so that was
something that was a big lead for us
just it was an accident too we hadn't
really thought this is how this is we're
gonna we're gonna make sure that we
don't have
you know that we're well ahead of the
competition because of this we just
lucked out that's so interesting
yeah but then later on later on
competition once apples were really
selling IBM was the first major
competition and when they got into it
they had this huge marketing arm that
went into every big organization in the
world and selling big mainframe
computers but it was easy for anybody to
buy an IBM you never get fired for by an
IBM so they had when they came out with
their PC it was very easy to get huge
huge sales and eventually it took it
took a few years but eventually they
surpassed the the Apple 2 in sales
that's exciting so you know to wrap it
up here we only have two minutes in
something seconds here the people that
got started initially with Apple that
did their parts that play their roles
all of that stuff you know with the
success of Apple how many people I mean
how many people ended up becoming
financial independence simply because of
Apple when they got started first couple
of years hard to say I think a lot more
become financially independent now
because if you get a high up executive
job in a big company your salaries now
are gun high but when we were a start-up
well there were five of us that really
ran the company for the first three
years and we pretty much had you know
almost all the stock so when we went
public that was what I didn't feel right
about I felt that everybody had been
around us was a part of helping but I
came from hewlett-packard and they had
profit sharing every quarter a certain
amount of the profit was given to the
employees of stock because you as an
employee should feel like an owner of
your company and I felt that so strongly
so I gave away a lot of my own stock to
almost everybody in the company and
marketing engineering jobs a certain
level of job and then I gave huge
amounts to a few key people young people
that were in high school that helped
enthused me and you know helped write
code with me in the early days wouldn't
have gotten to where I got to without
him and I thought they deserved their
part of it too they shouldn't be treated
like they aren't worth anything
[Applause]
commercial 1984 Super Bowl you know
which one I'm talking yes
what was the stymie I look at that come
on I get fired up when I watch the
commercial yeah tell us a little about
that commercial I had a plane crash I'd
gone back to college to get my degree
and Steve Jobs I was over one day and
Steve Jobs called me over to the
Macintosh building and said you got to
see this puts a big humanik tape in the
player and he's up and it goes through
that 1984 commercial and I've got to
assume that almost everybody's seen it
where the young track lady with a red
outfit throws an anvil in it there's a
big screen on the television saying
everybody has to think the same you know
kind of like the IBM world everybody has
to have the identical thought contrary
thoughts will not be tolerated and she
throws it and it explodes and
everybody's just gasping they see a new
world is coming oh my god that was the
most incredible thing I'd ever said
about incredible piece of science
fiction and to describe a company Ridley
Scott had done it and I said oh we're
gonna show this at the Super Bowl Steve
said no the board voted against it I
said why they said well they had some
some problems with the meaning and you
know I didn't get that he said and it
would cost $800,000
I said well by then Steve and I were
worth a bit you know maybe a couple
million each and I said I'll pay half of
it if you'll pay half you know and we
could still show it and we should
because this is us and I was so naive I
thought that's how things got done but
eventually eventually it did get shown
that the agency that developed that
commercial they deliberately didn't sell
off their Super Bowl time they kept
saying we can't get rid of it we haven't
been able to unload it but they were
really making sure it didn't go and so
we showed the commercial and that was
very lucky there's a you know still
rated the best commercial ever
hands-down for taking over a traditional
industry which is exactly what we want
to do with PHP Steve thank you for
joining us here and coming on into the
table
[Applause]
[Music]